for drinking doc up drinks these drinks
are gaga
I'm expecting a lot of Flash Lady Gaga's
very / pretty pillows although I will
say she's fun she's very calm yeah yeah
she got calm like reading Li she was
like very theatrical before and now
she's just kind of like glamorous I'm
willing to try for gaga this is kind of
what I expected I expected like mermaid
frappe no that's old lady gaga not
today's Lady Gaga really guys were more
fine and serious well like you said oh
it's good it's got lime coconut milk
that's what it is
it's like a pink tea watered down and a
little milky with a hint of lime I like
this I can drink this every day this is
good what what what is this I'm about
this so if you're wanting a green tea
this this would be disappointing because
it's definitely not but the more I drink
it actually the more I'm like oh it's
like an iced tea with a lemon and the
tea happens to be matcha tea it's more
lemonade than macho but I only can watch
oh you're crazy I love Starbucks as
green tea frappuccino that's that's
mostly not green to use oh really yes he
did you have you worked at Starbucks
before I don't order anything but dark
coffee it's very like maybe it's just
confidence
I'm just very opinionated blackberries
and tart hip-hip biscuits with that so
flour of course you know
I have no idea what this is this is
pretty sweet but actually I don't hate
it I like that this berries in it that
makes me happy I know you're into
berries yeah we got this hibiscus this
is hibiscus hibiscus every berry has a
biscuit Starbucks refreshers it takes me
to different places lot of different
flavors going on where's the water
there's like a flowery flavor there's a
little bit of milk from the coconut milk
I taste cinnamon am I crazy I think
you're crazy
I assume the sweetness comes from the
berry no I think the sweetness was at it
like a simple syrup and then I think
there's probably some kind of hibiscus
tea if you had strawberry ice cream
melted it and then put some strawberries
on top that's what it looks like if it
tastes like that it wouldn't be the
worst thing sure we sure we got pictures
really fast shall we alright we have to
stop the shoot of that to Instagram I'm
glad we match our drinks today whoa it's
like it is a yogurt it tastes like
strawberry yeah if you're looking for
kind of like a dessert type of drink
something sweet something refreshing
this is good why be approved I approve
you know all of these things would be
really good as a Frappuccino we all have
so many frappe so maybe refract out and
they wanted from down I think my
favorite would have to be the last one
the pink drink pink strawberries in it
stop stop that of it stop that right
stuff definitely the berry one berry yes
the violet one I think mine's between
the ombre a pink or the pink drink
they're both really good I feel like you
like this better
yeah maybe you had better reaction with
Jackie's
guys peace
[Music]